[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition and today
we're titling this one the house of
cards
i got with me of course chuck knight jet
hey neil
yeah yeah so though you are a stand-up
comedian
you have tremendous sports fluency so
that's a good thing just want to
put it out there it's probably the only
fluency i might have
okay too much information
or because you're working still working
on that comedy thing right yeah exactly
and i got gary o'reilly gary former
soccer pro from the uk
thank you very much to have you here
good to be here yeah yeah and i'm your
host neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist and let me just give a
brief overview of where we're going to
go
on this show because i'd like to say the
stakes are high
because the theme is poker
and uh red hot who's the famous poker i
guess uh james bond
would would like his uh chips stirred
no no he played
mustard oh backwards that's right he
and and maybe sometimes the roulette but
yeah it's less on the poker table i
think yeah
yeah and so we'll also find out what
state
space complexity is i don't i don't know
what that is
we're going to find out and whether
nash's theory of equilibrium this is the
famous mathematician
from princeton for which he got a nobel
prize whether it's a
key component in a winning hand
and we also wonder whether probabilities
and thinking about them can be an
asset in life or are they just confusing
and you should ignore them
and so all this is going to happen in
this program and we've got
several experts one of them in
particular is live bori
live welcome to star talk thanks for
having me
yeah yeah you're our first guest today
and you're a tv presenter i get get your
resume here
a writer science communicator love
science communicators you need more of
them
let's get more of them and then i could
go to the bahamas okay
that's what i want here right you're a
former championship
professional poker player and an
advocate of
effective altruism that's good that's
good and also
of course when you have that much stuff
going for you they get you on ted
you're getting ted talk here so uh you
had a first class honors degree
in physics and astrophysics love it
there it is
my people you're my people going out to
the world the university of manchester
and what else are your world series of
poker and european poker tour champion
have i seen you playing poker on tv i
must have
you might have done i don't know if
you've watched if you watched a bit of
it then you might have seen me yet i
have to see if you have shifty eyes here
just so i'll know
definitely well do you have do you have
a poker face live
is there is there an actual poker face
that you
dawn while you're at the table i mean
you're looking at it
everyone always thinks that a poker face
is about being completely stoic
and robotic which to be fair like that
if you're starting out that's a good way
to conduct yourself at the table because
it's just
easier to maintain but really what a
good poker face
is is just being relaxed
and natural and
showing that you're comfortable even
when you're not why not
why why can't a poker face be the
opposite
of what kind of hands you got if you've
got a two
four six and seven
right all different suits you look at it
and then you're like
that'll just freak everybody out just
look around the table and be like you
gonna lose
sure you could do that but the thing is
is that then if i'll very quickly catch
on it'll be quite obvious to your
opponents that you're doing that when
you have bad hands and you're doing a
scared face when you have good hands so
we'll just
we'll just adapt so you just have you
just have a portfolio of faces you draw
from
at any well that's the thing if you can
if you can randomize well
uh between you know okay this in this
situation i'm going to be 50 i'm going
to be 50 50 doing
or 70 of the time doing my scared face
and 30
of the time during my happy face um and
you can perfectly
randomize that then yes you're being
unpredictable but
in reality it's very hard for humans to
to randomize
what will happen is you'll get baseball
coaches given the probabilities of what
you're doing per hand
and then they'll talk about you know
because they have people who shift
places on the field
if you always pull the ball they're all
on the left side of the field right
and so i keep thinking why don't you
just punch it the other way and you get
to base it every time but then they
would learn that
and then compensate so there you have it
so there's probably a nash equilibrium
for that
yeah we'll get to that in a minute but
tell me first what is state
space complexity i don't know i don't
know what it is
uh state space complexity is uh one of
many
different measures of the complexity of
a
of a situation specifically it's used to
describe the complexity of games
um it's it's one measure of that so what
it technically means is like
the number of possible uh
states that a game can legally be in
from start to finish
so you know you're playing tic-tac-toe
um it's a grid of three by three
um that corresponds to a around i think
there's somewhere around
700 or so possible moves so that's it's
state space complexity is 700. and then
a game like chess
um with its you know it's a 8x8 board
that has a state space complexity
of about 10 to the 40. so as you can
imagine because of combinatorics the
numbers scale up really fast depending
on sort of
the number of possible positions and the
different types of pieces and so on
so that's why four-year-olds can play
tic-tac-toe and
not chess i mean basically yeah it it
generally corresponds to sort of
and not always to the difficulty of the
game but certainly for the difficulty of
the game
um when it comes to building an ai to
play it
and and if you sort of look at the
history of of ai
um over time where it's been pitted
against humans in different types of
games
um it's it's the more simple the game
the earlier it was either solved or sort
of you know the best humans were
defeated so like tic-tac-toe
um was technically solved by a computer
back in like 1952 i think
um connect four was somewhere in the 90s
and then chess
uh deep blue uh beat gary kasparov in
like 97
and then there was a big gap and then
you might have seen the
the uh alphago documentary um in 2015.
yeah and off ago is google correct is
that right well
deepmind who yeah deepmind okay
yeah let's be honest it's all google
it's all
google okay well that one was a big deal
because
go it still stays complexity is 10 to
the 170.
right that is crazy high all right so
now what
what would pogba just have to stood in
wait wait wait everybody
the name google when spelled correctly
is the number
you know 10 to the 100th power so
if anybody's going to solve something
that's got at least 10 to the 100th
things going on in it it's going to be
the company google
the google g-o-o-g-o-l i was going to
say but don't they spell it wrong
they can't even spell it that was early
when they didn't know how to spell it
now they don't now that is how you spell
it
there you go oh my god that is so true
that's how you do that
that is how you spell it now oh my god
that's hilarious
so tell me about the nash theory of
equilibrium uh when i was at princeton
spent some years there he would walk
outside my window and so i just see him
walking not
talking to anybody just kind of with his
head down sort of bobbing in
in contemplation solving the mysteries
of the universe
yeah yeah yeah because all right it's
one thing to know the stake complexity
of a game but
so what okay ai needs to know about it
fine
but now you want to strategize given
that fact so
tell us about the nash theory of
equilibrium yeah so
a nash equilibrium is basically
the the way you would describe like um
you know say you and i are playing
uh poker against one another just in a
one-on-one game
in theory i would lose clearly i would
lose just to put that up just putting it
maybe maybe over the maybe over the the
long term but you could win
because there's a bit of luck in there
which yeah we'll discuss later but um
so if we're playing um technically
there's
a strategy a sort of a strategy that i
could employ
where it's so it's so sort of perfect
that um your only option is to
adopt a similar strategy against me and
when we're both doing that
um we're basically breaking even against
one another
over over the long run and
it means and the reason why it's an
equilibrium is because it is
not there is no other strategy that
either one of us could sort of
try and do um in order to improve our
situation so it's basically a sort of
stalemate
effectively um and what it means is
basically
we're unable to exploit one another any
further
and does nash equilibrium apply only to
people
interacting in games and other sort of
people based systems
or does because then just call it the
nash stalemate right
but equilibrium equilibrium has a lot of
use that
word means a lot in physics you know and
so
to hear that a physics term get used at
a poker table i find a little disturbing
well it's it's it doesn't have to be
between people it can be between
technically it's between agents
so an agent could be an ai it's anything
that is it could be two computers
playing one another
okay and if they're programmed
absolutely the same way then they've
reached that
stalemate position right right exactly
and
so what it is it's just basically a
mathematical solution right okay
okay it's technically like a like a
local minima i guess
um and possibly a maxima um but the
point is is that
it all it means is that neither one of
us could
try and do something differently to what
we're doing and expect to make more
money
um in fact if we did that the other one
would now be able to start exploiting us
because they're technically playing this
perfect strategy
that sounds like a local minimum because
if you displace it in any direction it
goes back to that minimum
whereas a local maximum if you displace
it it might just drop down the size
right yeah i think yeah it's probably uh
one one for you and it's your next guest
you've got on the uh on the show
to ask the algorithm okay no i've been
hogging you this whole time
chuck no i i just
no i was just intrigued by that
conversation you guys were having
because
with respect to poker there is always an
x
factor so every hand has a
built-in probability because there's
only a
certain number of cards right so if
let's look at the equilibrium you and i
are exactly matched the x factor
is how i'm able to manipulate you
psychologically
how do you account for that well wait
chuck did you just invent the x factor
here in this conversation or is this
unknown
no i'm just
by definition it's already encompassing
any possible x factor you could think of
otherwise if
if if i hadn't encompassed it if there
was something that you could do
some x factor you could suddenly pull
out right um to
exploit me then i'm not playing a
perfect i'm not playing what's called
game theory optimal um i forgot to
mention that before so
it's called a game theory optimal
strategy where you're unexploitable
by your opponent so so this works in a
laboratory because in real life
i could never know you so well
as a human being that i could
account for every single thing that you
might do
however for the most part it you know
you
you can get really really close but
could i
are you saying that human beings just
like machines can be
predictable right down to
the thought that you are going to have
well it's not so much about
it it's not if you're playing game
theory optimal or an ai
is playing game theory optimal poker
it's it's not saying that it can
perfectly predict
what the opponent's uh what their
opponent is going to do it's not making
a statement about that
all it's saying is that it's playing a
strategy
that has without getting too much into
the weeds it's like a
it's perfectly randomized uh between
like bluffing and not bluffing
depending on the each little sort of
minutius uh decision point
um whereby the opponent cannot take
advantage of that
um so it's not it's not that it's
perfectly um
and and it works it works depe it's it's
actually independent of the type of
player you're playing against
but the interesting thing is just
because you're playing game theory
optimal uh
and so therefore you're not um you're
not your opponents aren't able to
exploit you
what it also means is that you could be
missing out on certain things that they
are doing
like say we're playing rock paper
scissors and you don't know anything
about me
the the best you know your your
your best option is to just perfectly
randomize between the three because that
way
you're not i i can't predict anything
that you're going to do you just use a
random number generator and and
33 each different thing um but if we're
doing that for a while
and then you notice that actually i i
throw rock every time
well now you'd be stupid to carry on
randomizing because
you're missing out on this opportunity
to throw paper every time and exploit my
dumb play
so that's sort of this difference and
that's a situation where you'd want to
deviate from your past sort of
game theory optimal strategy in order to
sort of capture all this this value that
i'm losing by being an idiot
so that's just you but it refers to two
perfect players then i mean that's the
thing that's that's what i was
to be saying like pure equilibrium then
yes yeah so that
that's the framework of your strategy
the real world
is on the clock so how long does it take
you to put this
into effect successfully well
i mean for me i mean i'm retired now so
i am far if i'm going to sat down at a
poker table i'm
i'd be far behind the curve of what the
you know the latest
you know the people who are getting the
closest to uh playing a game theory
optimal strategy
um but even then interestingly no human
can actually perfectly play it in fact
no computer can even perfectly play it
you can only sort of
asymptotically approach it kind of like
you know the speed of light
um and so
in terms of like how long would it take
me to get to the level
these days of a world you know true
world-class player
who's who's still sort of playing and
studying all the uh game theory optimal
solutions i mean
i don't even know if i could to be
honest these days i've been out the game
too long but
i mean it would take it would take
probably a few years
of intense intense studying and i think
the interesting thing about poker is
that
since we discovered that there are these
game theory game game theory optimal
solutions these sort of mathematical
solutions
the the whole sort of style of the game
has very much
changed and when i got back into it back
in 2005
it was still very much a sort of um a
black box no one really understood
what the mechanics of the game really
were and it was just very much more sort
of
people reading intuitive game uh where
people with sort of
the the most sort of street smarts and
and human experience were often the best
just because they could pick up on weird
quirks of human behavior better than
their opponents
um but then since the lid has been
lifted and we've seen the mathematical
workings of the game
largely due to sort of improvements in
computation and software
um now the best players are the ones who
just mimic computers basically and play
in this very mathematical
semi-robotic style and there is less
sort of uh
there is less of this intuitive people
reading although there is still some
that is a that's a weird fact that i
think requires a pause and even perhaps
a moment of silence
okay we play poker we invent a computer
that's better at poker than we are and
then we imitate the computer
that's just just let us give a moment of
silence for the human mind
there right all right all right because
we are not the best thinkers on this
absolutely what we invented as a thinker
is the best thinker
right that and what what neil is really
saying is let us have
a moment of silence for the death of the
human race
[Laughter]
because it's over for you it's over
that's the beginning of the overlord
there you go
right we're moving we're moving into the
nova scene yeah
so if you play everybody seems to play
poker online so therefore
you don't need a poker face right
because you're not looking at people or
are you
and then basically you've got no chance
of physical tells there's no oh i have a
twitch
they scratch their nose whatever is is
that is that why it's all disappearing
because poke has played online so much
now
um yeah great question um
to an extent yes um
as you correctly said you can't
physically see your opponent so there is
none of that type of information and so
that forces you to
to rely on the more mechanical
information
such as like the amount that they bet uh
the types of cards that they bet on
um the only sort of read you can make in
terms of sort of something physical is
how long they take to click the button
you know you can see how long they think
and that could be information like oh
they really thought for a long time on
this one whereas they normally act very
quickly that can be
informative to an extent we're about to
bring in a an ai expert on in game
theory
uh what what has been your experience
with ai before we make that transition
to our next guest
um my my experience with ai is just one
of
a silent obsession um i've just been
fascinated with the concept of
particularly super intelligence
um sort of for the last 10 years really
following i mean i was introduced to it
through
the effective altruism community now
tell me about that what
how does that relate to you this is a a
a not-for-profit that you started is
that correct do i understand that
correctly
yeah so i mean a few poker players and i
started a a
not-for-profit that sort of operates
under the effect of altruism principles
so those principles basically are you
know we
there's limited resources both time and
money
that both any individual or any society
or group could ever donate
to philanthropic causes and because
these resources are limited
um it's crucially important that we sort
of take a really
we take a step back and and sort of take
stock
to figure out what are not only the
biggest problems but
the most urgent and the most neglected
uh the most comparatively elected to
ensure that the money is
is donated to actually the best place
where you know there's
either the strongest evidence or the
highest probability
of having you know the the optimum
impact um
because unfortunately um most philanthro
by far the majority of philanthropy has
at least historically been very um
sort of emotion driven and and
reactionary and
a little bit vanity driven right it's a
person's pet project and they want to
solve it and they
they're not thinking about math when
they tooth exactly it hasn't
it deeply needed a scientific approach
um
and fortunately in the last 10 years uh
some a combination of scientists and
business people um actually a couple of
hedge fund managers really because they
got the money yeah well sure but they've
got the money but they've also got the
their statisticians at heart and they
care about data and they care about
evidence
and you know no one bats an eyelid at a
business
trying to ensure that it you know gets
the biggest bang for it for its buck so
why is it sort of why do people find it
strange to think that charities should
also try and get the biggest
impact for buck um particularly when you
know when we give to one place that
means we're not giving to somewhere else
and if that other place you would have
given to was actually going to save 10
times as many lives for the same
donation
it's kind of a tragedy if you ask me if
we don't give to the right place so
based on this sort of general concept um
there are
there are a number of charities that
have been identified as being
by far the most cost effective in terms
of like they will say you know your
money will just go so much further if
your goal is to
improve this makes so much sense i mean
it's embarrassing
we all should be embarrassed that it
wasn't around long before this
and you know and this is
everyone out there study your math okay
all right don't ever say i'll never need
this again
well maybe you will not that you'll need
it but you'll want it
to do something innovative like yeah uh
live worry is done
yeah and the other thing you could do
liv is uh just figure out
a way to uh robin hood uh jeff
bezos just steal from him on an annual
basis amount an amount of money that he
will not
realize is missing yes it's a few
billion that's all and give it to people
who need it well if but specifically if
he
with his philanthropy um not only you
know
it's one thing for him to do more but
even more crucially is that for him to
make sure that it goes
to the most uh cost effectiveness
right and that's the key thing and a lot
of times
because um you know so much pressure is
put on like no do something now give
away this now and it's like well
it would surely be better for someone to
take to take a year to figure out okay
where do i get 100x improvement as
opposed to give it all now just because
of like social pressure so absolutely
you know it's not as simple as
give it all away now mr bezos okay so
chuck this is how i would rather use the
x factor she said 100 x factor 100 x
improvement
right that's an x factor let's call it
right in fact you can rename it the x
factor
quantified x factors yes factors there
you go
guys we got to take a short break and so
we have to say goodbye
[Music]
goodbye not to olivia okay well
uh i it seems like you're like really
smart on a lot of things that we could
probably use you on future shows
so if you stay on our rolodex with your
permission we might reach back i'd love
to
very excellent all right guys
all right thank you so uh stay with us
because ai expert and
friend of star talk matt ginsberg will
join us on the other side
and we'll be talking about competitive
ai when star talk sports edition
continues
we're back star talk sports edition
house of cards is the title
with chuck knight and gary reilly guys
chuck chuck you're tweeting at chuck
nice comic thank you yes
that is correct sir and and and
gary my three left feet we're still
sticking with that
no matter what all right uh in this
segment we're picking up
ai and trying to see what role
that plays in in in in
gaming in in in probability
in making decisions and we're going to
juxtapose that with
all that we learned from liv boris um
libori's commentary about playing poker
and i wonder if she and
matt ginsberg are like the nemesis of
each other
right because they both come at the same
problems but they could be competitors
because there's gaming is a big part of
this
let's bring in matt ginsberg matt
welcome back to star talk
hey neil great to be back yeah and
you've got this this resume
where you like a young phd at oxford
that's kind of cool
although i think we have an
over-fascination with young precocious
kids um because no one when you're older
no one says boy that was amazing you did
that before you were 40.
you know that doesn't you know i mean
why we have such a fascination i'll
never know
but it's there and we had it with you at
age 24
getting a phd from oxford in mathematics
um
very cool and you studied computer
science at oxford that's of course in
the uk
and you're scientists i studied when i
was a i was a mathematician and a
physicist mathematical physicist
i am so old that when i was a student
you couldn't
study computer science oh not yet man
that's
old that is really old older than dirt
as my kids tell me yeah
so the abacus you would grease the
abacus
so you had to invent computer science so
other people could study it
[Laughter]
the first computer and i date to about
the same
so really yeah the first
the first commercial i mean i'm just too
old i'm just too old
actually my wife's phd is in
mathematical physics so
um i get my dose of that when she when
she wants to
uh think about the world uh with that as
a lens that works real good
uh so uh you've provided a statistical
support for
sports teams something we covered in an
earlier visit that you've
uh granted us and we loved your name of
your
crossword puzzle um algorithm
please tell us the name dr phil that is
the
best name ever ever so that was
ll that was my second choice
and my first choice i asked a bunch of
crossword constructors what i should
call this program
and my first choice was actually deep
clue
good uh good so what happened to that
instead of ibm wouldn't let me do it i
was going to say
oh because there's a deep deep blue blue
right
no but that would be that would create
resonance the idiots there what what you
know
anyway so dr phil was dr phil was a very
close second and that's what we wound up
calling it
okay all right so you're a specialist in
ai
and general solver of hard problems
and you're now gainfully employed at
google so
i tell me about um how you
think about the nash equilibrium when
you either program ai
to do what you need to do or when you're
thinking about
gaming in general for me even nash
equilibrium stuff that's just a tool
so when you look at the work i do on
statistical support for
selecting a play in the nfl you're
really solving
a fairly simple game with a relatively
simple payoff matrix you know
if i do a passing play and they call
a blitz what do i expect will happen so
you have this little payoff matrix
and you're just and you know wow so it's
much simpler than part of it than games
it's much simpler than
full-up games that have you know 10 to
100
possible states of existence right
i think it's fair to say that if you're
trying to invert a matrix
10 to 100 on a side you're you're done
so you have to whatever problem you're
solving you have to reduce it to
something that's computationally
tractable
all right so so when we think of poker
there's a you know bluffing is a
fundamental part of it
so if ai plays poker does ai
bluff absolutely does it have to or does
it have to
of course it has to if you don't bluff a
poker you suck
is i try to read my opponent right i'm
not playing the cards i'm playing my
opponent
can ai do that or is it just calculating
things
potentially it can i think i mean
there's been a lot of work on poker and
ai
a lot of it a lot of the foundational
work
involved translating the poker problem
into this
linear optimization problem with i
believe
billions of variables and then just
solving it because you can
it's not 10 to the 100 tenths of a 9 is
big enough so
you solve this giant optimization
problem and it says
okay if you're in this situation in
terms of betting and you hold these
cards
this is how you should bet and it
doesn't know but it's a bluff but it'll
say
even though you know you've got unsuited
2-4
you should still bet a lot with this
fraction
you know this fraction of the time so
there's your bluff and it's coming out
of the fact that you're looking for
a you know an optimal strategy according
to the nash definition
so an optimal strategy could include a
bluff is the point it has to include it
has to right
if you never bluff then your opponent
who i mean one of the nice things about
the nash optimum
is that if you tell your opponent i am
playing by the nash optimum
he can't exploit you so he can play
against you for days
and see oh he's just playing with ash
optimal i can't exploit that
but if you're not playing the optimal
strategy he will play against you and
wow it's like
this guy never bluffs cool that's yeah
there's the point of exploitation
right interesting interesting wow
interesting all right i don't want to
hog matt's questions chuck gary what do
you have for him
okay so we build an ai program to play
poker
simple enough are we cheating wait wait
so we're asking here
if you were assisted by ai yeah in a
comp in a poker competition
does that count as cheating and more
broadly how does ai play out in whether
in the rules of games about whether
people will declare someone's cheating
or not
what's the arc of that of that of that
line of thinking i think
i don't i don't think that so if you're
using an ai to help you
and you don't disclose it yes you're
cheating
okay because you're not supposed to it's
like it's like you know
going into a high jump with rockets on
your shoes you can't do that
i think the injury is hidden with hidden
rockets on your shoes
i think the interesting question is
whether
the organizers should allow it so you go
in and you do have a computer assistant
and you say hey i'm being assisted
or conceivably i just am a computer what
should the organizers do
should they let you play or should they
not let you play yeah but but put one
interlocutor in there and you have
coaches attached to computers on the
sideline
right giving instructions to active
players who themselves are not using the
ai but the coaches are
well that's the same thing that's my
point isn't it the same thing as you're
describing
that's that's using the computer and not
telling anybody just because you have
some guy in the middle i mean it's like
there's this
um there's a scene in galaxy quest where
sigourney weaver her job is to
when the computer says something she
repeats it to the to the crew
right and she says it's a stupid job but
somebody's got somebody's right and
and if you're doing you're still they're
still using the computer and the fact
that corny weaver's in the middle
doesn't
that doesn't matter so if you have a
computer that's telling you something
and you've got a guy with a
walkie-talkie passing the information
in you're still using a computer yeah
but that's allowed apparently i don't
think anyone's
prevented that from the beginning they
suppose they could have no computer help
no one ever said that they just and and
by the way even without the computer
they'd have somebody doing analytics
baseball is
rich with that as a history so so what
if a computer now does it
and yeah it's ai but so well there's a
difference between doing something
offline and doing something in the game
so in a chess game for example you
adjourn a chess game
and now everybody's going to run to
their computer and is that allowed
is that a lie it's allowed um
but what you can't do is you can't have
an earbud and somebody's telling you
what a computer thinks you should do
that this seems that seems like an
artificial
um uh rule boundary on this if i can
on a break i said i gotta go pee and i
go no that would be cheating but if
there's an official break and
because i saw this in the queen's gambit
right they all went and analyzed the
games
all right that's before computers but
you get other experts there and that's
the same thing
that's the same thing and and what
happens the boxer between rings sits
down
and the coach tells them hit him here
not there that and and so
it's an ai just not a fundamentally
different
thing it's just a matter of degree i
think
the answer is is sort of but i think the
distinction between
as the game is going on and during a
break i think is an important one
because the bottom line is you can't
police the brakes you can't tell
somebody
we're going to adjourn this chess game
come back tomorrow and don't use a
computer
how do you enforce that how do you know
whereas it's relatively easy to say we
don't want you using your computer
while you are playing that's that's much
easier to
then you can say you know now take that
thing out of your ear we don't like it
but we you can't say you know don't go
to bed tonight don't go home
just have a camera on you it's too much
i'm just thinking
do the casinos have their own ai
programs so when i if i played poker
online
with ai that they can work out i'm
cheating that's actually gary
i love that but i want to pick that up
in the next segment because we just ran
into this pleasure for this one
yeah so so when we come back we're going
to talk about whether the house
can use ai so that you don't people like
matt don't walk in there and exploit
their ignorance
because of his smarts when star talk
continues
we're back star talk got chuck nice i
got gary o'reilly
and matt kinsburg matt ginsberg is our
our
resident he's not in residence but he's
in arm's reach of star talk
he's our ai expert with his new gig at
google but we've got him on here to just
sort of unpack
gaming and what role ai might play in
the present and future of gaming and
gary i cut off one of your questions
once you put that back on
no that's amit thank you uh we need to
take a break um
so do the big casinos when you play
online have their own
ai program to patrol to make sure guys
like me
don't use my own ai program to win
at poker so it's the ai police for the
ai
yeah what should prevent them from using
ai
right to make sure you never win and how
long before we're in the weeds
so let me tell you what i know and i and
i don't know the answer here
i do know that they worry about this
so there was a there was a guy who was
just
mopping up on one of the online poker
sites
making money at a phenomenal clip and
they went crazy trying to figure out
what he was doing
yeah and there was an assumption that he
might be a computer or using a computer
and it turned out it was just a guy who
was really good at poker and he won for
a while and then
didn't go so well but they're very
concerned about that
on the chess sites it is a substantial
problem where somebody comes along and
they're using a computer and you can't
tell
they just have a computer running in the
background and they're playing chess
online and they're creaming everybody
and there is
a lot of interest in figuring is
in protecting the other players from
that so computers have a particular
style of play
and you you look for that one of the
things computers do in chess for example
is they almost never play really fast
even if they have just one move
they somehow for some reason the
software is arranged so it's going to
take them a little while to get out of
check the only way they can
and if you see somebody who just never
plays fast
that's sort of a tip off that he may be
using
a computer so people try and figure out
i mean they're aware it's a problem and
they try and figure out what they can do
about it it's a problem in
computer bridge in online bridge there
you're not looking at computers you're
looking at people just cheating by
calling each other up
hey i have the queen of spades
and you know and you got to figure out
if that makes sense so
so in all of these cases whether you're
using an ai
and not disclosing it whether you're
talking to your partner you're cheating
and finding cheaters has always been
hard and i think always will be
but people so one let me push back a
little bit with you on the chess
setups because as i understand it when
you play a game
you you are presumably honest about what
your chess
rating is and then you play other people
that have approximately that rating
and if you wipe the floor with everyone
because you're assisted by a computer
your rating goes up you can no longer
play those people and this and it
keeps going up until they will force you
into a place where other people
will have an equal chance of beating you
because you're playing people with an
equal rating
because the rating tracks your success
so isn't that a self-limiting fact that
prevents ai from running rampant in
chess
sites well computers are way better than
we are at chess
so if i wanted to do this i would go to
chess.com and i'd start an account and
it would rate me at 1300 and let's say i
can't play chess at all
and i would on the side i'd have a
computer and i'd say to the computer hey
play at 1500 right and then i would do
what the computer says and my rating
would go up to 1500 and then i'd tell
the computer hey play at 1700.
okay and i would always be a little bit
better than my opponents
and there you are eating lunch while all
this is happening right
yeah as you ascend okay yeah
there you go and i just march up the
ranks okay so matt you've thought way
too much about cheating i'm a little
worried about you
i worry we'll come visit you in prison
okay
okay that would be good because i'm
going to be bored
and he was like and by prison i hope you
mean uh
fiji because that's where i'll be kind
of like a
uh an ai version of andy dufresne yeah
maybe just
plotting and doing the doing the
governor's exactly and then finding his
way
anyway just to be clear and andy
dufresne from
uh redemption the not the novel written
by stephen king just and the movie
which most people saw okay justin and i
just left it out
i have no desire to be in a prison
somewhere
where the warden is a horrible sadist
and all i can do is think about
artificial intelligence while i wait for
the guard to beat me up that is not
a future that i that i really look
forward to
but one way the guard doesn't beat you
up that one will be okay
it's better that was a list of seven
seven
offenses there i mean if if ai i mean ai
will be better at poker than humans
i mean i kind of think we understand
that now so
when we watch poker tournaments are
people going to care if ai
is playing so the world chess
championship remains incredibly popular
people care how good
magnus carlsen is and um
because they're not giving a ticker tape
parade to an ai algorithm
so but i will tell you i don't get it so
my son just started playing chess and
he's having a great time playing chess
and he's playing chess all the time
online
and i'm like but computers are so much
better than
and he says dad i don't want to be the
best i just like playing chess it's fun
and i like watching other people play
chess i think you know
watching usain bolt run
was amazing agreed not and
and it was just amazing and there are
there are things that move faster than
usain bolt
but watching him was just it was like
almost a privilege just to watch
you know you know matt i gotta i have to
deeply agree with you
there and not that this is the first
time i've have agreed with you
um because when you think about the
vicarious participation in something
you want another human being to do to do
the act because you're a human
and my analogy here is the space program
right
it matters that a human being takes a
step on the moon
did you know that we had landers on the
moon before that
but did did anyone celebrate that we
knew it in the science community and the
space community but we were watching for
the humans
because they can come back and tell a
story you could touch them and you could
like i said you could put them in a
parade so i got to go with you on that
that there's real value to knowing it's
one of your own
your own species and performance in a
high in a high performance
so but but what about the fact that now
we have computers that can
experience and describe and tell that
same
story in a very human fashion
i'm still not giving it a ticket parade
dammit
i think
so i think the thing to realize
is um how different
computers are than we are so when a
computer plays chess it's not playing
like we do
when a computer plays poker solves a
crossword plays bridge
they're just not solving things like we
do
and i think neil is right that makes it
harder for us to relate to them
because they're aliens and i think
there's also
a wider message which i think is much
more important and that is
they're things we're good at and they're
things machines are good at
and they're going to be different things
and we're going to we're going to be
able to solve problems
working together that we can't solve by
ourselves and i think that's incredibly
important going forward
games are the world we are the children
let's solve the problem together that's
very
sorry to sound like that but i think you
totally sound like that
all right well what do you think about
this that's how it is
so what do you think about this then uh
in light of what you just said
the grafting of uh that same technology
into human beings so that
our intuition our
method of thinking is
enhanced and augmented by the sheer
computational power of
an artificial intelligence we'll just
make our mistakes that much faster
oh my god that is horrifying
oh my god that is so scary what you just
said
so this is this is this is sort of
interesting
and i think it's certainly worth trying
but if somebody said to me
i have a horse
and it has all these amazing properties
and
i have a dolphin
and it has all these other amazing
properties so let's
make a horse dolphin that might not be
the right thing to do
it might be i'm sure
and for the dolphin stuff you want to
use the dolphin well they did that with
the camel the camel
that's a hybrid it's an idea hybrid
right right
sometimes sometimes yes sometimes
you really want to you know we're good
at what we're good at
and and i have no idea you know elon
musk wants to put microprocessors in our
in our heads
and i i think i would i'm going to be
very interested to see what happens when
you put a microprocessor in someone
else's head
but i don't want to be early i'm not the
guinea you're not a first adopter
okay matt your program dr phil um
crossword solver but language is organic
it's always developing
right so how do you program something
to develop with something that
incorporates slang
and just goes in random different
directions but just to be clear
not everywhere does language develop i
mean france has a has a
has an official board of language that
restricts the entry of some words
and protects the presence of others so
you talk about a place where free
where communication channels are free to
utter any syllables you want to mean
whatever anyone else
thinks it means right so ai would not
do this at all so there that's why we're
better than ai because we can make
stuff up i'm trying to find out
how we can still hold on to our dignity
well just think neil words that were
slang words
street words from the 50s 60s
weren't in the lexicon maybe a few years
afterwards but now
it's almost like a common part of a
sentence so we are involved our language
evolves from street slang and it becomes
incorporated in everyday language i see
what you're saying right it
elevates its way yeah yeah so in a
crossword puzzle if i write a puzzle and
i have a clever word that's recently
invented
but not yet in all the formal
dictionaries but everyone
conversationally knows what i'm talking
about
your dr phil is going to miss it isn't
it
that is correct and it'll be a little
bit behind so there was a puzzle
recently
where that included the field gps's i
think it was in the crossroad tournament
this year
and gps's wasn't gpses it's how you
spell it
and that wasn't in dr phil's dictionary
and he couldn't get it
and it viewed it as this random sequence
of letters now
it can say well i'm so sure about the
crossing words
that i'm it's got to be a g it's got to
be a p it's got to be an s it's got to
be an e and an s
so i don't know what gps's is but i'm
sticking it in because
it's just everything else works so
it's also the case that dr phil's you
know one of the things that happened
this year with dr phil is i started
working with
the natural language group at berkeley
and they brought in this
it's a machine learning natural language
processing tool to do
sort of question answering that is
constantly getting trained
on new crosswords new data new
books new everything so you do see ai
evolving and you see tools like this
evolving so it's not a static dictionary
and it's not nothing
nothing is static and by the way
it would the same way that we become
exposed
to colloquialisms the ai would be in
that same position too it might be a
little behind
but at some point it's going to have an
exposure as well
and if yeah and if you look at the work
that you know apple does with siri when
you
ask syria question that siri that
question goes to apple
and it's part of their
database of uttered language so when you
use
slang off it goes and the first time
somebody asks siri a question that has
some weird word in it siri's going to
have no idea but then it just keeps
getting keeps showing up this word keeps
showing up
so siri eventually figures out what it
means and is it true
is it true that like well all the search
engines who use the natural language
that when they ask you back did you mean
right when you put something in it's
because they're actually
learning if that's how people ask for
stuff
a little bit mostly when they say did
you mean it's because they don't know
what you they don't know
and their natural language module said
oh he might be mean this and he might
mean that and i don't know which one
and i'm just going to ask him okay matt
let me ask you because i think i heard
something
what you just said in an answer ai
doesn't have the capacity to guess
it has to be accurate
so i don't so i think i one of the
berkeley guys actually put this
incredibly well
machine learning systems don't know what
they don't know
so i remember i so
in the crossword tournament the um
the humans solve the puzzles and then
they get passed into a room where they
get they get scored and i typically
do some of the scoring as well as
running dr phil and i remember once
i got a puzzle back and
it was done incredibly quickly because
you'd grade it on speed and i got this
puzzle to grade
and the guy had solved it in like a
minute and a half
and then it had one quarter that was
just all random and wrong
and i remember grading it and thinking
this guy's an idiot
he took a minute and a half to solve the
puzzle and he surely knew that this
corner was totally wrong
and i looked at it and it was dr phil's
puzzle it was my puzzle
but then the problem was that dr phil
had solved this corner completely
incorrectly and had no idea was wrong
it doesn't know what's guessing it just
says well
this is the best answer i could come up
with so i'm gonna go with it
and i don't know if it's right but it's
i think it's right it's probably right
one of my favorite clues that i've ever
seen it was uh
four letters and the clue was um
to come in second
lose okay yes lose
lose but but that wasn't where my first
urges were come and say is it win
place and show is it this this and we
when we we don't think of the person
coming in second
as losing because i guess it's the we
want everyone to get a trophy or
medal or something i think in ancient
greece there was no second or third
you either won when you didn't win in
the original olympics as
you're just not you're not competing
second place is the first loser i mean
that's really that's all there is to it
and that's how i was brought up tough
crowd tough proud
that's the uh that jerry seinfeld has a
whole bit on that
you know of all the losers you came in
first
[Laughter]
so matt tell me about uh random numbers
and their role in this
do we have a perfect random number
generator yet or are they just
good enough um
we certainly have perfect random number
generators right there no i thought that
was not possible
i thought cosmic cosmic ray detectors
are perfect
oh fine fine okay fine but not not
in a computer we will never have a
perfect synthetic random number
generator that's that's what i was
asking okay
but but you can come very close so for
example you can have a clock that
measures time in billionths of a second
and you can look at the last three
digits of that clock
to start your random number generator
and that's
that's almost random it's hard to
imagine it being meaningfully correlated
with anything else
right right and so this matters when
you're calculating probabilities
in your gaming uh software isn't that
correct
yes because there are times when you
need a random image reader going back to
the very
the example we started with nash
equilibrium you know what you want is
you want to be say
you want to run a passing play 30 of the
time in a rushing plane 70
of the time you need to flip a coin and
you need to decide
do i go with the third or do i go with
the 70 and you have to generate a random
number
so anytime you're you know in a poker
player
obviously you can't bluff all the time
you can't bluff none of the time you
need a random number generator
but i think we we have random number
generators that appear to be good enough
okay so that's a wonder i just wanted
that that's an update for me on the
state of that
of that effort but guys i think we're
like actually ran out of time on the
subject
of random projects yeah run out of
random numbers
we just put in the last random number
ever again
anyway matt are you active on social
media can you remind us
um i i don't understand social media
i i mean i wrote a book facts man that i
try and promote on social media i will
certainly tweet about the fact that we
did this today
and that's that's about as as clever as
i get
i don't have facebook and how do we find
you is it just matt ginsberg
or matt gansberg.com com and and your
twitter
handle what do you have it's matt l
ginsburg
and okay and i think matt ginsberg was
taken
and that's okay that's all i know all
right and so uh good luck at google
sometimes you need a little bit of that
too
but um yes much appreciate it all right
guys gary always good to have you chuck
my friend and matt thanks for being a
good sport with us
it's always literally figuratively and
you know we'll come back to you because
this is a hot topic
cool all right i'll be here this has
been star talk sports edition neil
degrasse tyson
you